♪ ♪
>> Greg: JIMMY FALLON HOW TO
GOVERNOR CUOMO ON HIS SHOW AND I
TELL YOU THIS BECAUSE OTHERWISE
NO ONE WOULD EVER KNOW.
ONCE AGAIN, JIM HELD AUNTIE’S
FEET TO THE FIRE HAMMERING HIM
ON THE PREVENTABLE DEATHS THAT
OCCURRED IN NEW YORK’S WEST
HOMES AFTER HE FILLED THEM WITH
COVID PATIENTS.
NO, JUST KIDDING.
>> WHAT PHASE OF DATING ARE YOU
CURRENTLY IN?
>> ZERO.
I MET PHASE ZERO ON DATING.
THERE IS NO DURATION ON PHASE
ZERO, THERE IS NO AUTOMATIC TIME
THAT YOU GO TO PHASE ONE.
YOU COULD STAY AT PHASE ZERO FOR
MONTHS.
I THINK NEW YORK CITY WILL BE
FULLY REOPENED BEFORE I GET OUT
OF STAGE ZERO.
>> I THINK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP.
YOU WERE THERE WHEN WE NEED TO
DO AND YOU STILL ARE THERE.
>> Greg: I FEEL AS BAD AS
JIMMY FALLON’S HAIR.
I GOT IT.
I’M TOLD FALLON HOSTS A COMEDY
SHOW BUT HAS THERE EVER BEEN
POLITICIAN THEY GOT MORE PRERIDE
FROM THE PRESS THAN CUOMO?
HE HAD HIS OWN PUBLIC RELATIONS
ARM OVER AT CN.
>> THIS WAS THE ACTUAL SWAB THAT
WAS BEING USED TO FIT UP THAT
DOUBLE BARREL SHOTGUN THAT YOU
HAVE MOUNTED ON THE FRONT OF
YOUR PRETTY FACE.
DO YOU THINK THAT YOU ARE AN
ATTRACTIVE PERSON NOW BECAUSE
YOU ARE SINGLE AND READY TO
MINGLE?
DO YOU REALLY THINK YOU ARE SOME
DESIRABLE SINGLE PERSON?
>> I THINK BEAUTY IS IN THE EYE
OF THE BEHOLDER.
>> Greg: WOW.
THAT THAT REALLY KILLED.
LITERALLY PEOPLE DIED DURING
THAT ACT.
BUT SOMEONE OVER AT CNN HAS
STONES.
>> ANDREW CUOMO SEEMS TO BE ON
SOMETHING OF A VICTORY TOUR
CONGRATULATING THE STATE AND
HIMSELF WERE DEFEATING THE VIRUS
EVEN SELLING THIS POSTER SHOWING
HIS STATE GETTING OVER THE
MOUNTAIN.
IT INCLUDES REFERENCES TO HIS
DAUGHTERS AND A BOYFRIEND,
LITTLE INSIDE JOKES.
THERE ARE NO ILLUSTRATIONS
HOWEVER OF THE MORE THAN 32,000
DEAD NEW YORKERS, THE HIGHEST
DEATH TOLL BY FAR OF ANY STATE.
>> Greg: THAT WILL MAKE THINGS
TENSE AT THE CNN CAFETERIA.
CUOMO ALSO SAID THIS.
>> WE ARE WORRIED THE INFECTION
WILL COME FROM THE OTHER STATES
NOW BACK TO NEW YORK WHICH WOULD
BE A REAL TRAGEDY.
>> Greg: IT’S ALREADY A
TRAGEDY AT LEAST FOR AMERICA
GIVEN THAT 65% OF THE CASES THAT
SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY
ORIGINATED FROM NEW YORK.
HE ALSO BRAGGED ABOUT THE
STATE’S DECLINING INFECTION RATE
BUT THAT’S WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
RUN OUT OF VICTIMS.
STILL THE MEDIA HAVE PREFERS TO
FOCUS ON FLORIDA EVEN THOUGH
NEW YORK HAS EIGHT TIMES AS MANY
DEATHS AND NEARLY TWICE AS MANY
INFECTIONS IN FLORIDA IS ROUGHLY
THE SAME POPULATION AS NEW YORK.
BUT THE GOVERNOR LOVES TO SMEAR
FLORIDA AND ODDLY, SO DO CNN.
LOOK AT THOSE HEADLINES?
AGAIN FLORIDA IS RUN BY A
REPUBLICAN THAT CHRIS CUOMO’S
BROTHER, THE GOVERNOR, DOESN’T
LIKE.
SEEMS LIKE THE PERFECT SHOW FOR
A MEDIA WATCHDOG SOURCES.
I’M TOO BUSY WATCHING FOX KICK
THEIR NETWORKS BUT, HOWEVER BUT
UNLIKE CUOMO I DON’T CONDONE
VIOLENCE.
ALL RIGHT JESSE, LET’S GET TO
THE IMPORTANT POINTS.
FALLON’S HAIR.
YOU’RE IN SHUT DOWN, I MEAN SHUT
DOWN, OUR HAIR LOOKS GREAT.
WHAT’S GOING ON WITH FALLON?
>> THAT LOOKS LIKE BED HEAD.
BUT SOMETIMES IF YOU ARE
HOLLYWOOD, THAT HEAD IS A LOOK.
I DON’T KNOW, BUT I JUST WANT TO
KNOW WHAT KIND OF CONDITION OR
HE’S USING BECAUSE THAT LOOKS
LIKE SOME NICE FLOW.
I KNOW WE ARE A LITTLE TIGHT ON
TIME BUT THE ONLY THING I WOULD
SAY IS TRUMP GAVE HIM A STAR,
GAVE HIM EVERYTHING HE WANTED,
AND IT WAS LIKE THE TRUMP AND
ANDREW CUOMO SHOW.
THE ONLY GREAT THING THAT HE DID
WAS LOCK THE CITY DOWN CHINA
STYLE.
THAT WAS A VERY VIGILANT
LOCKDOWN EVEN THOUGH HE WAS LATE
A LITTLE BIT AND THEN HE
INFECTED EVERYONE IN THE NURSING
HOME SO IT’S A MIXED RECORD.
AS A POLITICIAN, POLITICIANS
DON’T TAKE OWNERSHIP.
THEY PASS BLAME.
THAT’S WHAT MAKES POLITICIANS
GOOD POLITICIANS.
>> Greg: DANA, ISN’T THERE
ANYBODY THAT WATCHES THIS STUFF,
THIS LOVEFEST AND GO, THIS IS
BAD TELEVISION?
IT’S DISGUSTING, AT LEAST TWO
HUMAN BEINGS.
>> Dana: AND IT’S NOT LIKE
THERE HASN’T BEEN REPORTING
ABOUT THE NURSING HOMES, IT’S
OUT THERE.
PEOPLE CAN READ ABOUT IT IF THEY
CHOOSE TO BUT IT WASN’T JUST
FALLON.
I WATCH CBS MONDAY SUNDAY MORNIN
OF THE MAIN ANCHOR DID AN
INTERVIEW WITH CUOMO ABOUT A
MONTH AGO.
THIS WAS WHEN THE DEATHS FROM
THE NURSING HOME OR MUCH MORE
RAW FOR THE FAMILIES THAT WERE
GRIEVING.
NOT A SINGLE QUESTION, BUT A LOT
OF QUESTIONS ABOUT HIS DATING
LIFE AND HIS FUTURE FOR A
POSSIBLE PRESIDENTIAL RUN.
IT’S EXTREMELY WIDESPREAD AND
IT’S IN A REMARKABLE P.R. QUEUE
WITH GOVERNOR CUOMO AND I DON’T
KNOW IF ANYONE COULD EVER REPEAT
IT.
>> Greg: JUDGE, CAN’T YOU JUST
RUN FOR GOVERNOR SO WE CAN FIX
THIS?
>> KNOWN.
THE MOST DISGUSTING PART OF THIS
WAS WHAT THE GOVERNMENT DID DO
WAS SEEK OUT A BILL PASSED THAT
HE SIGNED INTO LAW WHICH PRETTY
MUCH GAVE IMMUNITY TO ALL THE
HEALTH CARE OFFICIALS AND
EVERYONE ELSE FOR CIVIL AND
CRIMINAL CASES AS A RESULT OF
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE NURSING
HOMES.
OUTRAGEOUS.
HE WAS WARNED.
HE WAS TOLD NOT TO SEND INFECTED
PATIENTS IN.
ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE DIED WHEN
THEY DIDN’T HAVE TO DIE AND HE
INFECTED PEOPLE IN NURSING
HOMES.
AND HE’S ON A PUBLICITY TOUR
ABOUT THE SIZE OF HIS NASAL SWAB
OR WHATEVER THAT WAS THAT HIS
BROTHER WAS TALKING ABOUT, IT’S
HORRIBLE.
>> Greg: YES.
JUAN, I HAVE TO GIVE JAY CREDIT
FOR DOING THAT AND AS RON
GREENWALD SAID, YOU CAN SPEAK
TRUTH TO POWER IF YOU ARE NOT
THE GOVERNOR.
>> Juan: THAT’S RIGHT.
IT’S NOT AS IF CUOMO IS WITHOUT
FLAWS BUT YOU DO HAVE TO SAY
THAT THIS DAILY BRIEFING THAT HE
HELD PROVES TO BE VERY POPULAR
BECAUSE IT WAS INFORMATIVE.
I THINK HE FILLED A VACUUM WITH
INFORMATION, A VACUUM THAT
PEOPLE WEREN’T GETTING FROM THE
PRESIDENT AND THE SECOND THING
TO SAY WAS, REMEMBER.
YOU HAVE A BIG CITY AND A BIG